booktv.org
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome everybody uh welcome to our
third colloquium series uh of the year
uh i'm very very delighted to introduce
dr natasha waraku who is an associate
professor at the harvard university
graduate school of education uh
dr ward crew is an expert on the
relationships between education racial
and ethnic diversity and the cultural
processes in schools and universities
her first book titled balancing acts
youth culture in the global city
analyzes youth culture among children of
immigrants attending low-performing high
schools in new york city and
comparatively with london
i won't go into details of the second
book which is the topic of our exciting
talk today or her exciting talk today so
in addition to her books natasha also
has many many many many papers that are
published in prestigious journals and
popular presses including the american
journal of education the british
education research journal poetics
ethnic and racial studies ed week la
times and the washington post
as an aside and for those of you who are
my students in my class right now i've
long assigned uh one of natasha's pieces
for our classes which is a beautiful
review of the cultural explanations of
uh educational inequalities um she also
has a numerous number of grants and
awards from the american sociological
association british academy national
science foundation nuffield foundation
and russell stage foundation natasha
completed her phd in sociology from
harvard university and her bachelor's in
science and arts in math and philosophy
from brown university so join me in
warmly welcoming dr baraku
[Applause]
[Music]
um thank you thank you for that nice
introduction it's really um a delight to
be here i conceived of many of the ideas
in this book when i was
on leave at the russell stage foundation
in new york a few years ago so it's nice
to be back having actually written the
book and having it you know tell a
coherent story which it wasn't quite
there yet a few years ago
um so this book is about is there is an
echo in the room is it okay yeah okay um
this book is about how students at elite
universities make sense of race
meritocracy and inequality uh in the
united states and britain um and it's
really a sort of qualitative look at
these and i just realized i have no way
to i don't have a clicker
oh thank you
and so um and so i'm going to talk a lot
this is really kind of a focus on the
student's perspective
but i want to start by just talking a
little bit about inequality the united
states and britain are highly unequal
societies and unusually unequal society
so if you look at
this graph this is just if you look at
the horizontal axis here this is telling
you the genie coefficient that is the
relationship between basically what
wealthy people earn and what poor and
the working class earns in in a society
and so you can see the united states and
britain are higher than almost all oecd
countries in terms of that that
inequality
only surpassed by kind of emerging
economies and the vertical axis here is
intergenerational mobility that is the
relationship between what someone earns
and what their parents earned again a
high level of inequality meaning that we
have higher levels of correlation
between what we earn
and what our parents earn compared to
again other oecd countries so high
levels of inequality um low level lower
levels of intergenerational mobility
than kind of similar countries
this is also true by race
if you look at net worth and another
measure of inequality is actual wealth
median wealth for whites in the united
states is 13 times greater than median
wealth for blacks in the united states
and 10 times greater than median wealth
for latinos in the united states
this is also true in britain
if you look at unemployment
job status accommodation homicide we
have racial inequality in britain as
well so these are highly unequal
societies and i kind of came to this
project trying and wanting to know um
uh
how elites make sense of their
accomplishments in a highly unequal
society so and how do they make sense of
racial inequality in particular and so
you know i thought that this would give
us clues about how inequality gets
perpetuated how do social policies get
past that continue to maintain this
inequality um and you know when and and
in particular when um inequality when is
highlighted and when we know that there
are high rates of inequality how do
people
and especially those who are the winners
make sense of our ideology of equal
opportunity
um and i thought this would give us
clues about kind of how we might think
about shifting the way that we think and
talk about race and class and
achievement to more accurately reflect
our opportunity structure and the racial
realities in our society
so i decided to look on elite university
campuses in particular because these are
places where many elites come of age um
even if they weren't elite before they
entered these institutions and so how
students on these campuses think about
race and merit matters a lot
they'll go on to make decisions about
you know working in the media
hiring decisions
social social policy decisions and so
they'll take with them their
understandings of what a fair system is
what equal opportunity means how to
select people in a fair way with them
and as they go on to these positions in
the future
and i also remembered my own experience
on an elite residential college campus
many years ago i won't say how many
um where you know we talked a lot about
race um into the night with you know
many of my my fellow students and i and
i was living in britain at the time and
noticing how um this conversation about
race was almost non-existent on the
college campus the university campuses
that i was on and so i was curious about
how this experience in residential
higher education is operates differently
in the united states and britain and how
that shapes students perspectives
differently in the united states we also
have many kind of race-based policies
and diversity-related policies we have
for many for many decades departments of
african-american studies
affirmative action on most selective
college campuses
and
some places have kind of race-based
student centers and in britain again
none of those things really exist so how
does this shape the way that students
think about these issues
across these two contexts is a question
that i was really interested in
so how do students national and also
university context shape that meaning
making so in the book i also talk about
students at brown and harvard and how
they're different as well and i'm going
to talk about that comparison today i'm
happy to talk about it in the q a but
i'm really going to focus on this kind
of u.s uk comparison
um
so um
so i'm going to so
okay so
sorry so how university context shaped
that meaning making and i focused in on
admissions because this is a kind of
highly contested um
domain in which um people have a lot of
opinions and a lot of thoughts right not
just related to affirmative action but
affirmative action is a big part of that
story and that's at that intersection of
merit and race in particular
and we know that um admission to these
elite universities is unequal right so
um if you look at this
this chart here we see that about 15 of
students on the harvard and brown
campuses the two sites of my research
are black or latino
compared to about a third of young
adults in the united states we also know
that about a third of um adults in the
united states have a collet of a
bachelor's degree compared to um
almost all 85 percent of students on
these campuses having uh parents with a
college degree
so unequal both in terms of educational
um uh background as well as in terms of
race this is also true in britain um
where about seven percent of young
adults are black or south asian and i'm
sorry 14 of young adults are black or
south asian compared to about half of
that on the oxford campus
and
the big kind of cleavage of inequality
that people talk a lot about in britain
is what kind of school that people go to
and about half of students on the oxford
and cambridge campuses come from private
schools compared to seven percent of
young people in britain
so unequal again in terms of educational
opportunities um and related to race
and so the puzzle then is how do
students make sense of this inequality
and especially when
they're sort of here this narrative of
you know working hard in high school
most of them work incredibly hard in
high school most of them are going to
schools in which most of their peers are
not getting into these universities so
it's easy to feel a real sense of
accomplishment on the one hand on the
other hand we know this data that
suggests that um the outcomes are pretty
highly unequal
um
so
how so and the last question that i
address in this book is how what the
implications are of that meaning making
especially when we think about this
diversity-related policies and practices
so okay so what might we expect how
might we think that students would think
about race and admissions so on the one
hand we might take a kind of symbolic
politics approach and symbolic politics
is a theory in political science which
says that
our our ways that we think about policy
issues are related to kind of
long-standing ways of kind of political
dispositions they're emotional kind of
so if you so if you think of yourself as
liberal you're going to support a firm
of affirmative action you're going to
support the welfare state um kind of
social welfare policies um and those are
those are more likely those kind of
identities are more likely to shape our
political views than our say our own
self-interest our narrow self and
individual self-interest
so this would suggest that oops um so
and we might think of um
[Music]
of uh admissions to elite universities
as a particularly salient um kind of
some um political issue it's something
that people think and talk a lot about
so so um so uh you know there are always
articles in the newspaper both the
united states and britain about
admissions to these places both related
to affirmative action and access and and
otherwise as well so here's a here's a
story from the guardian in britain um
here's the story about the rankings it's
always a big news item when the rankings
come out every year in the washington
post um you know there's always that
student who gets into all eight ivy
league colleges um that always makes the
news it's from cnn
and bbc news about
about college admission so this is
something that is very much in the
public domain and we might expect people
to have very strong views about
admissions to these places
now um the majority of students on elite
campuses like this identify as liberal
and so we might expect a kind of liberal
critique right and this would mean in
the united states that we need more
class and race diversity um it's hard to
argue with that when you see the data
that you saw earlier um and in britain
um you know much more class defined
society we need more class diversity
perhaps students might be thinking about
race as well more recently
on the other hand there might be a small
minority of students who have a kind of
conservative identity um and you know
amy binder has a great new book if you
haven't seen it called becoming right
that talks about kind of conservative
campus activists
um and you know the united states the
conservative critique is
we need to end affirmative action right
make it class-based this is sort of the
argument that you hear in the united
states
the british kind of admission system
which i'll talk about in a second is
already kind of conservative but perhaps
students might argue that you need to
favor the exam or the interview in the
admissions process
so that's the sort of
symbolic politics approach on the other
hand we might see a process of kind of
what i call status legitimation that is
that students might just reproduce the
language that their admissions offices
say related to admissions which would
legitimate their status as winners of
this highly competitive contest right
they've just gotten in they have an
interest in saying like yeah that was
fair because i worked really hard right
um and that's a kind of self-interest
story and so
if if there is if this is what's going
on status legitimation we would expect
students to basically say what their
admissions office is saying
and they might be different but they
would say that the admissions is fair in
their national context right and that's
the right way to do admissions
and so so these are sort of the
different ways that we might think about
um um how students would think would
sort of grapple with these two issues of
inequality and meritocracy um and and
that that sort of contradiction
so okay so let me tell you a little bit
about this study um this is a stu this
is kind of an interview-based study i
sent my graduate students out to
interview students on the harvard brown
and oxford campuses um we interviewed
students across racial lines i'm going
to talk
just about the white students today i'm
happy to talk about the students of
color um in the q a
um and um also spoke with um some deans
of admissions looked at a lot of
the campus literature online etc and so
just to get a sense of of how the
institutions thought about their work
related to to these questions
um
so um and
and i mentioned earlier i'll focus in on
the us uk different uh comparison as
well
so okay so let me tell you a little bit
about admissions before i get into some
of these findings um
so um
most of you are probably familiar with
admissions to universities united states
it's a very complex kind of system
with a lot of different kinds of
information the essay exams
letters of recommendation
the sat the g your gpa
and the harvard dean of admissions talks
about an expansive view of this is all
from something he wrote
in the new york times an expansive view
of excellence
extracurricular distinction and personal
qualities
and diversity and i want you to keep
those key phrases in mind as we go to
and when you hear as you as you hear
from the students and what the students
are talking about in terms of admissions
in britain admissions is quite different
there are national and university exams
so you first you take your national
exams and if you get kind of beyond a
particular pretty high cutoff score
you're kind of eligible then you can go
and take
some of the subjects that you might
apply to have a university exam you got
to take that exam and if you qualify
then you'll come for a campus interview
and unlike interviews in the united
states you're going to be interviewed by
academics in your field of study so
these are the professors who would then
be teaching you so obviously they have
an interest in admitting students who
they feel like are you know
quote-unquote teachable which is um
which is a part of the the the um one of
the sources of inequality that that
others have identified in admissions in
the uk
um
okay so the admissions website talks
about academic abilities
and aptitude for your subject and i'll
just read you a quote from the director
of undergraduate admissions at oxford um
he said to me
we're taking students who really only
need be really good at mathematics and
he's talking about for people who are
applying to study math at oxford it
doesn't really matter whether they've
got any social skills or have any
interest in liberal arts or humanities
or whatever as long as they're good
mathematicians and so again you can hear
very different way of thinking about
what merit is in britain
so that's the context in which students
are kind of thinking about admissions in
these two places so i'm going to start
with some of my findings in the united
states there's two pieces of
parts to kind of how students thought
about admissions in the united states um
one is that they thought of admissions
as needing to be calib evaluations is
needing to be calibrated according to
someone's circumstances so you know if
you've had if you've been um you know if
you come from a poor family and you
don't have a lot of educational
opportunities then that needs to be
taken into account if you have if you've
come with a lot of privilege and you've
gone to like you know very elite high
school that also needs to be taken to
consideration in terms of looking at you
your the whole picture
so um
so that these are kind of calibrated
evaluations of individual merit
according to life circumstances the
second piece which i'll talk about in a
second is collective merit so let me
stick with calibrated merit for a second
i'll read you a quote from a student i
call naomi and she says if you had a
very hard life but you did let's say you
got a's and b's instead of straight a's
but you had to work like 20 extra hours
a week than another kid then i think
that speaks a lot more than if you got
straight a's because if you had because
you had to provide for your family or
help provide for them so i think it
should be taken into account
um and so there's this idea that that
that should shape um evaluation so that
so we those people who are interested in
inequality might say well that's a good
thing right that they're sort of taking
this into account
now um related to calibration the ways
that students thought about calibration
was related to the ways that they
thought about race and the role that
race plays in society so i have a
chapter in the book where i talk about
students what i call their race frames
that is how they think about the role
that race plays in american and british
society
um and i'll tell you about two of the
race frames um
right now and how that shaped their
views on calibration
so um so the first um way that um
students one of the ways was a kind of
color blindness frame that is that race
doesn't play a significant role in
society apart from its coincidence with
class right and about half of white
students in the united states had this
perspective now if you think that race
doesn't play a role apart from its
coincidence with class you think that
calibration should be only by social
class
so here's a student a brown i call him
alex he says i think they should
consider socio-economic background and
the difficulties that people have if
you're from the same situation or
background you face the same problems
like if a white kid had had the same
kind of upbringing with parents of the
same income level as a black kid i don't
think the black kid should have an
advantage over me if we both came from
the same background so again um
really um uh
saying that this these are that these
are kind of separate kind of issues
right class and race um and so on the
other hand a minority of students and
this was predominantly student of color
but there were a few white students had
what i call a power analysis frame and
this was a frame in which students saw
the significance as rate of race as
playing as having um a shaping kind of
unequal power relationships in society
related to race um and it really
emphasizes the way that power operates
through racial inequality
and so for these students um they
understood the ways that racial
inequality in particular affects
minority youth and they thought that um
that um it was a a separate sort of
thing than race and so for those
students they thought that calibration
should happen both by race and by class
um and so
um so so this is sort of calibration
again variation according to the ways
that students think about race um but in
overall calibration was pretty common um
among most students
now the second big part of admissions in
the united states was this kind of
notion of what i call the collective
merit of the cohort and again i think
this is going to sound familiar to most
of you if you um have ever been a
student in the united states and that is
that everyone has a hook and together we
make a kind of diverse group that um
that leads to better learning
better overall college experience right
it's the way that diversity kind of gets
sold in the united states
um and so this was related to a lot of
different kinds of diversity and a lot
of different kinds of um kind of pieces
of merit right it could be you know
you're a great musician you're an
athlete actually you're a legacy even
and and race is part of this as well
so here's a student talking about
athletics and the student says i used to
think that having athletes who are quote
unquote less qualified i no longer view
them as less qualified i view them as
qualified in a different way
and i was really surprised to hear
students talking about legacies in this
way legacies meaning that
if your parents went to the university
you get kind of a leg up in admissions
and i thought shirley students would
reject that
so here's a student us one one of the
students at harvard who said given the
people who went to harvard are much more
likely to donate to the university and
continue donating to the university if
their children go to harvard i think
that's a reason to advantage them in
admissions so you know remember harvard
has this kind of 30 billion 30 billion
plus dollar endowment but and yet you
know there's this idea that um
bringing in that money is is a reason to
kind of advantage those students
now when students perceive all admits to
have a hook that gains them admission in
this kind of really incredibly
competitive process
being black or latino becomes another
form of diversity
um and so here's a student oren who says
ethnic diversity adds as much to the
class as somebody who's a world-class
piano player it's just a different sort
of diversity to add so you can hear this
kind of problematic kind of
commodification of race for black and
latino students right and there's an
assumption that um all black and latino
students on campus are benefiting from
this
kind of this this this this
consideration
um now this kind of um way of thinking
about um
admissions coupled with what i call a
diversity frame um leads to support for
affirmative action now the diversity
frame is this that student that that um
race is a um
is a cultural identity that shapes
individuals world views and cultural
practices in positive ways so diversity
so race is this it's this positive thing
it's something to celebrate it's a kind
of multicultural perspective and this
was um nearly universal this this
diversity frame and i should say that
these frames are not mutually exclusive
so students could hold a diversity frame
um as well as say a power analysis frame
or you know less commonly diver um
power analysis and color blindness but
this was very common among all student
white students and students of color
alike so um
so uh and that leads to support for
affirmative action and i should say that
whenever we ask students should the
university consider race or ethnicity in
admissions
um the most
common response was that yes
and so that we can have a diverse
student body which in which we have a
rich kind of educational experience
right so i didn't hear in response to
that question as much of kind of yes
because it affects people's life chances
oh yes because there's racial inequality
now
both of these kind of pieces of the kind
of admissions kind of perspective has to
have downstream consequences for race
relations on campus so i'm going to turn
to that now what are the consequences of
the ways that students think about merit
the um
the first one and the this is the title
of the book that um the diversity
bargain is this that's why students on
these campuses support affirmative
action in as much as it benefits
themselves and it benefits themselves
through this kind of you know creating
of this diverse um
environment
and so you know as long as it kind of
contributes to their own kind of
educational experience they're for it
but this has certain expectations that
that that come along with that view
and the first expectation is what i call
the integration imperative
and that is this that students um
are expecting their black and latino
peers in particular to integrate because
that is of course what they're they're
seeing as they're for right so here's a
student um
who said at harvard who says yeah i
think harvard's a pretty diverse place
but i think that diversity ends up being
a lot of different groups that sort of
self-select and associate with their
particular culture i don't know that
there's much interaction between the
groups and then we asked
anna to elaborate on her perspective and
she said it really bothers me because it
makes it really difficult to get to know
people because i'm not in any of those
like i'm not going to join the black
students association and most of the
groups i'm in are not and i think she
means race to find here
because if they had a white student's
association they'd probably get in a lot
of trouble
i think it's just sort of sad because
the interaction i've had with people
from different backgrounds have been has
been so great for me especially coming
from a school where there wasn't a lot
of that
so you can see a few things in ana's
words one is that um you know it's
really about her own experience and you
know what that's bringing to her own
experience and i don't want to be
misunderstood that there there's a lot
of social science research that shows
that there are incredible benefits to
this to this interracial interaction
people's views shift they become less
racially racially prejudiced there's a
whole host of research that show that
shows these benefits um but i want to
argue that that focusing on that alone
is problematic for some of the reasons
that i describe i think the other thing
to notice is that she really focused she
says that the black students aren't
coming to integrate with me i'm not
going to join the black students
association right so it's the idea of
students of color needing to integrate
into white spaces rather than rather
than her kind of making um um
making that leap in in the other
direction
and there's again there's there's a you
know equation of a black student's
association with a white student's
association again a lack of recognition
of kind of inequality and why we might
have one and not the other on these camp
these historically white um colleges
okay and the second implication is what
i call the reverse discrimination script
and that is that students were really
anxious about affirmative action leading
to what they perceived as reverse
discrimination and that if it went you
know too far that that would sort of be
a result and so um we asked students
about whether they'd ever experienced
racial discrimination felt they'd
experience racial discrimination and
this student says if i hadn't gone into
harvard i would have felt i'd been
discriminated against
excuse me if someone else that i knew
and who was equally qualified and who
was a minority if they'd gotten in over
me
and so i call this a script because it's
sort of this this this this kind of
script that's ready to deploy the
student got into harvard right um it's
hard you know it's hard to you know
so there's no opportunity that has been
um
forsaken and yet this script this
narrative is out there this worry this
fear is out there
uh
as a result um because then it stops
benefiting him
and the last um part of this diversity
bargain is this kind of essentialized
understandings of race and ethnicity and
it means that you know if um if black
and latino students are here on campus
to edify me white student then they need
to have a particular kind of experience
that is different to my own that i
perceive to be different to my own in
order to kind of
enrich me
so um here's a student i call karen who
says i don't think because someone
checked the black box or like the latino
box that that should be what helps get
them in you know maybe in their
interview they find that like since
they're latino they've done all these
things that make them add something to
different to the cultural fabric of
harvard
i know people who are like a quarter
mexican who got the latino scholars
award and their entire experience has
been a white experience
so she has a very specific idea of what
it means to have a latino experience and
the student doesn't fit that and so
she feels that that student shouldn't
kind of benefit from this
and that there is an expectation again
to contribute to the cultural fabric of
the university
so this diversity bargain is really
embedded in the way that students think
about merit and race
um and the last thing i'll say and this
is kind of more kind of as a preview to
the british case is that there were kind
of i got this sense of that a lot of
students were kind of evaluating their
peers they're looking at their peers and
wondering well what got you again and
what got you in uh were you oh i see
you're you're a musician and there's a
sort of again an assumption about their
black and latino peers about being you
know quote unquote less qualified right
a lower test scores etc
and so you can imagine that kind of
climate that that can create
um
okay so
so um overall students kind of really
echoing and in the book you see i kind
of do this comparison of what the words
that students say and what you see on
the admissions office is like literally
just their websites and it's uncanny
those kind of parallels right and then
you have these sort of consequences of
the way that they think about this
related to race
i'm going to turn now to the british
case which is much simpler um
[Music]
because they have very kind of standard
simple criteria based on individuals
one student said oxford has a very clear
stated aim and that's to maintain its
position in an intellectual society
another student said ultimately we
should just be blank faces we should all
just be admitted totally on marriage so
again that phrase merit sort of get
taken as a given
here's a student who went to an
underperforming high school
and the student says i think it should
be very much based on merit rather than
on background i personally if i knew
that i had been positively discriminated
publicly discriminated as a kind of
british phrase for affirmative action
for being from a state comprehensive
school i think when i came here i would
find it a lot more difficult because i
would feel that i hadn't earned my place
to be here so i think these different
ways of thinking about admissions also
has this kind of unintended consequence
of affecting the ways that um you know
non-traditional students think about
themselves and their place in these
universities and i you know i didn't
hear this kind of language in the united
states this feeling of like i shouldn't
be here right where that this student
felt and other student and and other
students as well in britain
um and so in britain students didn't
really have um didn't really talk about
calibrating evaluations of merit it's
like you get the highest score in the
math test you get to come to oxford to
study math um and nor was there any kind
of idea of collective merit which is a
very kind of american thing
so here's a student who says come came
from a very elite boarding school he
said you get to oxford as a result of
your education no matter how naturally
brilliant you are you have to be well
educated and the wealth distribution in
society means that white people have
more access to the best education even
in the state sector the state schools
are of lower quality in my belief in
areas of greater ethnic density so
there's an acknowledgement of unequal
opportunities but that kind of
perception of unequal opportunity
doesn't change the way that students
think that admissions should happen
right but that's kind of a k-12 issue
not
a higher education issue or oxford's
problem
as some students talked about it
um so um
okay so overall um
uh british students had very different
understandings of merit compared to the
united states students right um a kind
of very kind of blank slate approach in
britain a much more kind of complex
approach in the united states but what
they share in common is that in both of
these national context students are
really reproducing what their admissions
offices say really to a t right they're
just kind of almost regurgitating what
they've been hearing for so many years
as they've gone through the admissions
process and they land on campus and that
gets kind of reproduced again
and um
like the u.s students they largely don't
critique what their universities do
and in britain there was a different
diversity bargain in britain
white students expect accepted all of
their peers as intellectual equals so
this was slightly different from the u.s
where i heard all of these kind of
mumblings of like well i you know i
wondered how that student got in and
cetera
but i didn't hear as much of that there
was kind of an ex tacit acceptance of
minority peers the the the small number
of minority peers on campus but there
was also a kind of bargain that they
entered that they sort of expressed in
britain and this was in exchange for um
first and foremost no vision
for increasing equity in admissions
outcomes and you heard that earlier when
the students really sort of say well you
know unequal opportunities but
um you know that's too bad so one
student said underrepresentation is a
problem but it's not oxford's problem
another student says i've had friends at
oxford who have come here and frankly
not been bright enough and have
struggled and have had a miserable time
i don't think that's fair it's miserable
being at oxford if you're not good
enough oxford isn't the kind of place
where your tutor is going to spend extra
time teaching you i mean it's kind of
ironic because these universities in
britain are public universities and they
also have a tutorial system right where
you have this one-on-one and one-on-two
kind of teaching system which one would
think is a
better way to sort of help students who
haven't had the same educational
opportunities and if oxford's tutors
aren't prepared to take on the
responsibility of getting the people up
to scratch that's not fair to anyone
and so and then the student so you know
talks about this and then makes clear
that she thinks that it's not the
university's role to help those students
she said the responsibility in my
opinion lies with primary schools or the
secondary schools that's where the
problem is not at this level
and so again there's um you know a
recognition of inequality but a lack of
recognition of a role for the university
to play in attenuating that or
addressing it when students arrive with
different levels with different skill
sets
and the second piece of this diversity
bargain is that there's a real denial of
minority peers experiences
and so um uh
i always feel uncomfortable when i read
you this i'm going to read this quote
that i find i feel like i should give a
trigger warning or something when i read
it
but this student says i'm slightly
irritable when it comes to people crying
wolf and by that i mean doing what they
do best which is you know playing the
race card saying is it because i'm black
that really annoys me because it's so
unfounded in england i mean there were
plenty of pretty severe racist incidents
on the oxford campus just when i was
doing this research so there's plenty of
racism um
uh in in england and on the oxford
campus in particular but the student is
really denying that it's so untrue you
see racism so much in other countries
which we don't have here um so again
there's this denial that this is even an
issue in british society
and she was not the only one to express
this and i just want to give you an
example here i don't know if i don't
know if this made it to nyu but at
harvard
there was a campaign um by some students
called we are all harvard which was
about um how black students felt
excluded from the campus and they held
these placards and
kind of described that describing kind
of microaggressions that they had
experienced and um so oxford a few weeks
later came out with i2m oxford and this
this student says
wow your english so is a quote she's
quoting someone she says well your
english is so great and she says thanks
i was born in london hashtag unimpressed
um so this kind of took off and
interestingly um
institutional responses were quite
different in these two national contexts
but what happened a few days later
surprised me even more which was we have
this we are all oxford as a response
this was a group of students who wanted
to counter that message um and you can
see her placard you probably can't see
it tara placard says we enjoyed
celebrating diversity at the ousu the
oxford university student union
international fair
um so again a kind of denial that of the
experience of the young woman right
before um in her kind of critique of of
the university
and so there's this denial and there's a
chapter in the book where i talk about
this kind of culture of racial jokes and
the way the students talk about racial
jokes which were rampant um and really
part of a kind of elite um
uh private school culture that came to
those campuses as well
and again a denial of minority
experiences
so um so overall um you know this
there's this kind of story of status
legitimation in both of these very
different national contexts so very
different ways of thinking about race
and merit but very similar in students
basically expressing the narratives that
legitimate um
their own success they really reproduce
this language of their administrators
and in doing so they're embracing a
process they know to have results in
which disadvantage groups are funded are
systematically underrepresented
students assume that their definition is
the best of the best the most fair one
the one that brings the most deserving
students to campus and of course the
kind of unspoken follow-on is that there
are the students who don't get in are
undeserving or less deserving
um
and interestingly you know i kind of
started this thinking that well if we
have all this public discussion that
maybe that's going to kind of put a
crack in in these students beliefs in
this these systems of meritocracy but in
fact it might kind of exacerbate beliefs
and meritocracy so when that is when
your status is called into question um
you might sort of cling to it a little
more and and this is what um mary
jackman talks about talked about many
years ago in her in her book the velvet
glove she talked about how you know well
legitimation may actually be this this
desire to legitimate one status may
actually be exacerbated um when it gets
called into question and when there's
this kind of public discussions of
inequality
um and overall you know these these
these universities um and it's not just
these top universities it's
most selective universities are getting
increasingly selective right so um every
year you know there's like i'm sure nyu
does this every year there's a campus um
newspapers article lowest admit rate
ever and it's supposed to be a signal
that you know our quality is improving
our status is rising right this is this
is something to celebrate right there's
this belief that you know becoming more
and more exclusive
excuse me is a good thing and it fuels
this belief in meritocracy
and it leads to what you know joseph
soares calls an ultrameritocracy
and we know however that research shows
that when systems become more and more
exclusive it leads to greater inequality
in in terms of the outcomes and more
reliance on these kind of quantitative
measures like sat scores that we know
are um
have racially biased kind of outcomes
um and then needing to compensate even
more with prop you know programs like
affirmative action which are on kind of
shaky legal ground
um and i also want to point out that
universities also play a role in this
legitimation they their status is also
at stake again because you know the
university is trying to climb those that
status hierarchy of you know the the u.s
news and world report kind of rankings
right and so um
there's this kind of policy feedback
loop right where um they think about
there are um kind of
they are talking about admissions in
particular ways um and students kind of
repeat that and then they will go on and
take those beliefs and the ways that
they think about race and meritocracy
and equity and opportunity into you know
the the job the the world the labor
market when they leave these
universities and i think it's important
for universities to really think about
the production of these views and what
that does and how that perpetuates and
equal plays a role in perpetuating
inequality and providing little vision
for reducing inequality especially
racial inequality
so you know it might be that
self-interest kind of dominates over
symbolic politics remember in the
beginning i talked about these two
different juxtaposed a kind of symbolic
politics view with a um
uh
self-interest perspective and it might
be that when status is at stake or
there's a significant investment in the
system of rewards that that
self-interest kind of dominates and this
need this desire to um
to um
to protect that that that kind of
legitimacy and that status
um
you know when these students are working
incredibly hard they're um they're
getting in they feel this real sense of
accomplishment i can understand that um
but it sort of um perhaps then leads
them to to to these these views
so overall i really see this this work
is illuminating how these systems of
reward are not just about the rewards
they meet out and i think it's important
to consider the kind of knock-on effects
of the way that we do these these things
um they also shape and they also and
reflect as they reflect individuals
meaning making another domain so today
i've talked about how they um affect
race relations on campus and in the book
i talk a lot more about race relations
you know i talked about the the culture
of racial jokes in britain in the united
states about the ways that students
interact or kind of have this fear of
being perceived as racist and how that's
tied to these views um in the united
states as well
so i'm going to stop here and i'll look
forward to your comments and questions
thank you
[Applause]
thank you again natasha for your uh
exciting and wonderful talk um and for
gracing our department of applied
statistics social science and humanities
um right now if you have any oh great
one question
um
i'm gonna be the mic person
thank you um i had a question in regards
to the british students that
had a denial of there being a problem of
racism in their institutions do you
think that they're subconsciously doing
a comparison to like institutional
oppression and the history of racism in
the us and other places and maybe
subconsciously thinking well we don't
have the establishment of hbcus here or
the or the need for that so maybe we're
not as racist because we don't have that
history so i'm going to ask you repeat
the question because the echo is making
it hard for me did you say what that
they they don't have that in britain so
can you repeat the question i'm sorry
sorry the echo is a little hard to yeah
sorry so i'm asking if british students
maybe they're doing subconsciously a
comparison to institutional oppression
and racism in britain uh comparatively
to the u.s because they don't have that
history maybe of like the necessity to
establish like an hbcu because up until
sometime in the 60s most institutions
didn't even accept black people so um do
you think that maybe they're thinking to
themselves well we don't have that same
problem here so we don't have an uh it's
not overtly racist
in britain yeah
absolutely i mean there is um you know
the us looms large in britain um as it
does in in many countries and there is
definitely this idea that the us is a
race-oriented society but we don't have
race here we have class right and the
reality is is that there's plenty of
racial inequality in britain and there's
plenty of class inequality in the united
states right and we know that like
there's data that shows that um but
there is a a lack of a kind of narrative
about racial inequality that's slowly
changing in the last few in the last few
years there's been a little bit more
talk there was a report i remember when
i was in early years of this research i
found this this table on the oxford
admissions website that showed um
admission statistics by race and for
black
british black um
there was i think there was one student
who got in this one year and i thought
that i just assumed it was a typo and
then two years later this this um
counselor came out in the government
member of parliament and he basically
like blasted that he wrote an op-ed and
said like you know there are colleges is
that in there so the college system
where no black student has been admitted
in five years and so there's plenty of
exclusion um in britain it's just not
kind of in the public domain people just
don't talk about it because they don't
think about their society as a kind of
racialized society and you know i think
in the united states we at least pay it
a little bit of attention you know i
clearly argue in the book we can do a
lot more but we have the history of the
civil rights movement which really sort
of you know and desegregation and um
this really put race front and center in
the united states in a way that i think
was a helpful start you know i think we
have a long way to go but i think that
that is different in in the uk for sure
the uk they think of themselves as a
kind of post-colonial society in some
sense right um
and um but even that is very muted you
know britain kind of sees itself as as a
sort of benevolent
post you know that that was a sort of
benevolent colonizer um
so um yeah i think that's good thanks
um hi um my question is uh were you able
to collect data or do any comparison
about how students attitudes might have
shifted according to the discipline that
they were in um their major
um how far along they were in
in the like undergraduate process like a
first year versus a senior
and the level of interaction that they
had with faculty of color
or even staff of color like that work in
their dining halls and things like that
if that impacted it at all
how they understood this
yeah that's a great question so you're
asking i think about how kind of the ex
the college experience shaped their
kind of views and their their their
experience so um you know i didn't yeah
i did try to look systematically at
students by year but i
feel kind of i had enough data to really
conclusively say that but what i will
say is that students talked a lot about
their views shifting
um and it was you know especially
related to this idea of collective merit
a lot of students said you know well i
used to think but you know i think you
heard it in the the one about athletics
i used to think that like it's not fair
recruiting's not fair but now i see like
they create school spirit so i think
it's a good thing and affirmative action
was one of those as well so you know i
had a student who um talked about being
the
daughter of a politician a conservative
politician who said that you know well
my dad's views really shaped me when i
got here i realized that diversity is
such a great thing and it really has
enriched my campus experience so now i'm
in favor of affirmative action so those
are the kinds of things that
that you would that i would see and in
terms of you asked about
faculty of color
major discipline yeah
yeah
yeah i mean sociology i have a little
bit of a bias towards sociological i'm a
sociologist so i don't write this in the
book but i did notice but kind of didn't
you know i didn't feel confident enough
to say this because again because of my
own lens but there was a student who
said that you know sociology is
basically a history of like inequality
in the 20th century um in the united
states and did talk about how they
learned about um they understood racial
inequality and the production of racial
inequality and in a way that they didn't
before that um so
again i because i didn't this was not
designed to sort of look systematically
by dis discipline i'm hesitant to sort
of make any kind of causal claims but
certainly that was there there's also
this you know um
there's a little bit of a um you know
it's hard to know which way the causal
error goes but the way the story that i
tell in the book is that students kind
of come to college with their kind of
dispositions right in terms of how they
tend to see the world those get shifted
and disrupted as they come to a new
place they're away from their families
they're at an age where they're kind of
primed to change the way they think
about the world they're encountering all
these new ideas different peers and so
they might shift right but there's
certain students who might be attracted
to taking that kind of sociology 101
class or that sociology of race class
right and but i do think that those
students then gain a language that they
didn't have before to kind of make sense
of kind of inst their kind of gut kind
of ways of thinking about the world
um the other piece of this story is that
um
the the kind of orientation programs at
harvard and brown so i didn't talk about
the harvard brown differences um
brown has this orientation program
called the third world transition
program
which is a pre-freshman orientation
program where about half of the students
of color attend and it's a very kind of
political um
experience where students you know the
workshops in that that program are like
racism sexism colonialism ableism and
students talked about that as a really a
lot of students talk about that as a
very transformative experience right
that you know they say well i was just
coming this sounded like a cool thing or
i wanted to come to campus early and my
whole world view was shaped by that um
and so i think that's kind of an unusual
um
uh
program but it does suggest that that
being on campus kind of
shapes the way that they think about
race um and you know and fosters this
kind of power analysis view of race um
ed brown in particular for those
students of color who attend
so that's another kind of way that the
university not through classes but
through this program shapes their
perspectives
so
thank you so much um
i had um
uh first just a sort of a clarification
question because i
thought that the admissions process at
oxford is done by colleges and so every
college has its own admissions process
and so first of all could you just
explain a little bit more about how that
works and and who you actually talked
with when you say you spoke with the
undergraduate admissions officer there
yeah um and then i wanted to invite you
to say a little bit more about your
interviews with the students of color at
both places i'm really curious to know
how things were different for them yeah
um
so
yeah so so i didn't talk about that
because i didn't want to kind of
complicate the picture but admissions is
done so oxford is um
comprised of separate colleges right
students apply to a specific college and
they
um it's unclear how they make those
decisions i think part of it is you know
so there are colleges that are known for
being kind of old elite um you know
those are the ones that haven't admitted
a black student five years and there's
others that are known for admitting kind
of more working class students and a lot
more that are kind of in middle of the
road right and so students apply to a
particular college um
and i interviewed students at two
particular colleges um just
for yeah you know methodologically just
to get a narrower sample um and these
were colleges that were kind of middle
one two of those kind of middle of the
road like not super elite not super kind
of non-elite um and also in terms there
are tables that show like the
achievement levels of the different
colleges and they were again in the kind
of middle 50 percent
um the there is a director of
undergraduate admissions
across the university um and so it's
unclear how much
you know what how much power he has it
seems like over time it's becoming a
little more centralized there's a little
more of kind of trading going on between
the colleges so let's say a college
rejects a student they might go to
another college they might that student
gets back into the pool if the student
says yeah i'll go to any college and you
know there's another college that's
looking for more students and again i
don't know exactly how those processes
happen that kind of you know that
wheeling and dealing at the end it
probably has to do with like how many
spots they have for particular majors
etc etc um so that's the sort of
colleges it didn't seem to affect the
kind of story like they didn't you know
talk about
the colleges being different in terms of
admissions and what they're actually
doing
um the students of color i don't even
know where to begin um they're you know
they're very different they have a
different perspective so you know in the
u.s um students of color as you might
imagine don't buy into this diversity
bargain right they don't see themselves
and they shouldn't as they're to edify
their white peers they're there to get
an education just like everybody else
um and they um
they they did appreciate diversity like
their white peers um and you know i
think
white students and students of color
often had a different understanding of
racial diversity so those students at um
the third world transition program for
example talked about coming there and
developing these cross-racial
relationships because of course students
of color are diverse right coming from a
lot of different backgrounds a lot of
different perspectives and talked about
like getting to know um peers of
different ethnic and racial backgrounds
whereas the white students then would
come and say well all those students of
color come and they become friends with
each other before we even get here and
we don't have you know i mean some
access to them right because they're
already friends um and so saw them as
more of like the group of students of
color the white students and so so um
you know again a different kind of way
of thinking about race racial diversity
um they
were more likely to have a power
analysis perspective but it was not a
majority view among black and latino
students
either was about half
and
i don't think any of them expressed a
a color blindness
perspective
and so
and they also talked about this kind of
angst and this kind of tension and and i
talk about this today in my talk but
this kind of interracial tension on
campus right so like
um and this sort of anxiety that kind of
exists between white students fearing
you know being called racist or being
seen as racist and the students of color
like you know bringing with them kind of
very racialized experiences and worrying
about what their experience is going to
be like on campus and that sort of that
clash
in britain um you know the students of
color um
like that working-class student that i
quoted
seemed to really buy into the culture
and the kind of eliteness of the
university much more that you know
i'm here because i worked hard and you
know a few of them had a kind of almost
a culture of poverty perspective on
other people of colo you know people of
color or or you know immigrants and
their children
um and just seemed like there and it
made me think that almost perhaps to
make it to oxford as you know a person
of color in britain or second generation
was the category that i used that maybe
you have to kind of embody this kind of
identity as a sort of elite and you know
someone who kind of buys into the system
in a way that i don't think you needed
to in the united states um they did
however um the one thing exception to
that i think was this kind of culture of
racial jokes and they talked about how
you know people say it's a joke and but
if you don't go along with the joke then
you're seen as like you know like a
debbie downer and like that you're just
you know you're you're like no fun um
there's really no kind of way for you to
enter into that critique now i should
say that you know historically and even
today there are some kind of more
radical students on the oxford campus i
didn't go out and seek them
and i think um
they're very small in number and i think
it kind of i looked up so i had i'd
heard about this organization this kind
of group i'm forgetting the name but of
um kind of uh radical oxford students of
color um and when i looked them up that
that kind of group had sort of morphed
into a tutoring program for local youth
right so i think that that power
analysis frame just students don't have
access to it in the same way and it
might be that if you have that kind of
disposition you're not going to come to
oxford right because it's known to be a
place where there are very few racial
minorities and it has this particular
culture and students talked about that
that you know my black friend um didn't
want to apply here and went to
um you know
a college in london and you know the top
college in london because thought they
would be happier there um and you know
you can understand that perspective
given the culture on that campus but
again i think that just reproduces this
culture and like there's no real sort of
way of shifting it when um you don't
adapt it so that students of color are
you know have a better experience and
then more people want to come
so um so yeah
thank you so much for your talk natasha
uh i wanted to go back to the beginning
of the talk where you started talking
about decision makers as those emerging
from these elite universities uh and you
talked a lot during the talk about
feedback and reproduction yeah well also
acknowledging of course there's some
transformation in the experience of
being at university yeah so i wonder
from your comparative research design
you chose two places that both had high
inequality and low social mobility do
you expect differences with other
university experiences if you were to go
to other spots on the distribution in
terms of these questions of merit and
diversity yeah
so that's a good question i do think i
mean we know if we look at kind of the
continent
that
it's interesting that our
in the united states but also in britain
um we have a very
unequal higher education system right
there's like oxford and cambridge and
then there's the you know the russell
group and then there's the red brick and
then there's the four you know and in
the u.s we have like the elites that
kind of you know there's like rankings
right there's the state schools and then
there's all the way to kind of community
colleges right unselective you know most
colleges are not selective the united
states and then um two-year colleges and
in in your in the continental europe
there's a lot there it's a lot flatter
right people are more likely to go to
the university in their town there's a
lot less variation between universities
so there isn't this thing of like
getting into that top university in the
same way that we have it in the united
states and britain and that coincidence
i don't think is i don't think that's a
that's a coincidence i think it's
because these societies are structured
unequally and higher education emerges
on unequally in order to kind of
you know place people in this stratified
system
so uh you know if i had to predict again
i'm not an expert in in other parts of
europe but if i had to predict i would
say that there is a lot less kind of
investment in these kind of systems of
meritocracy and there is some
quantitative research that asks people
about you know do you think that yours
you know people are paid according to
their you know some measure of merit i
mean i remember what measure they use
and um
americans are most likely to say yes and
then there's also a question about do
you think this is a good thing americans
are also more likely to say yes that yes
we should be paid according to you know
our how how good we are at something or
our qualifications or what have you so
um so there is a stronger belief in
meritocracy in the united states um
and um
and again yeah i think that that's not
coincidence when you have the stratified
system then everybody wants to be at the
top but when it's more flat you feel
like okay if i you know do a good job
i'll get into a university and i can do
do what i want to do and i'll have to
and there isn't this sort of scramble in
the same way and we know that that leads
to less unequal outcomes when it's a
more flat system right
one last question
do you think that the marketization of
higher education in the u.s lends itself
to this inequality like for example the
us news and world report a lot of
colleges and especially in the top 100
uses to benchmark themselves against
each other so they look at things like
admissions and the amount of donors that
contribute to the university to like let
themselves and go higher on that list do
you think that
students being looked at as consumers
and what their return on investment will
be after graduating kind of lends itself
to how
this inequality persists in the u.s
because students aren't looking to
become whole
individuals or something like that or
global citizens they're looking to see
what their salary is going to be and not
what type of person they'll become when
they graduate yeah so um i kind of i'm
hearing two questions in there one is
this question about rankings and what
that does there's a great new book um
called engines of anxiety if you're
interested in this question by um wendy
espelato and michael sotter where they
talk about the impact that rankings have
on universities like what administrators
are doing in response to these rankings
and trying to kind of increase their
status in the rankings and this is a
sort of you know everyone and you know
when universities compare themselves
they're always looking up right they say
that their sister universities are the
ones that are like just above them right
and so there is this sort of scramble
when you have a hierarchical system
everyone wants to like move up right and
what that does is that kind of that can
often neglect the needs of the most kind
of disadvantaged students or the
students who need that you that that
education the most right so um
merit-based scholarships are like a big
thing now for like you know not the most
elite colleges but like you know right
below there because they're trying to
get those top students
um and to again to increase their
rankings that increases your median sat
score your your gpa
um so i do think that there are damaging
effects of those rankings that colleges
are responding to um that kind of foster
greater inequality um and you asked now
i forgot the second part of the question
oh yeah yeah
yeah
yeah i'm not sure what that's going to
do i mean i would say that you know
these universities i mean these are very
exceptional universities and that
they're so elites and i chose them
because
i thought that these would be places
where students wouldn't have the same
anxiety about like oh if it were a
different system i would have gotten
into harvard or the ivy league or oxford
or cambridge um so i chose them very
deliberately because of that but
in a way they get a pass on the return
on investment because i mean in other
research
on students like places like this they
say well i've got the harvard degree i
can major in philosophy and art history
um but it doesn't matter because i have
a harvard degree and that's very unique
to these elite places um
i don't know i feel like higher
education kind of mass higher education
is changing dramatically you know and
are we going to have like a
credentialing system i don't i don't
know what the what the next thing is
going to be um
and yeah i don't know that i can i can
speak to that given given this research
but i think it's an important question
what that's going to look like
sasha i had a question about um so you
you illustrated this uh this incredible
tension that a lot of the white us
students uh talked about in terms of
their conceptualization of diversity so
first it has to be something that uh
there's the demand for integration so we
are diverse but we must interact
otherwise what's the point of diversity
so that was one and the second one was
but at the same time you cannot be too
much like the mainstream if you are too
much the mainstream then it's just then
you're not actually diverse right you
almost lose that yeah it makes me think
of the literature on acceptable
diversity yeah on how
you know very middle upper class white
suburbs will be very into this diversity
but what they actually really mean are
actually maybe perhaps asian americans
right not black or latino um so i was
wondering in in the interviews
how did students reconcile or do they
reconcile at all this tension of
diversity meaning two seemingly
paradoxical elements yeah
that's a great question you know it
didn't come up because and i you're
talking about in the united states i'm
assuming because it's a very american
thing and i think it doesn't come up
because
um
those students of color get certified by
the university as like good minorities
because they've gotten into harvard and
brown right and so students said things
like you know i've never met someone who
doesn't deserve to be here right they
really felt like
okay like all my peers are legit right
and so i think because of that like
they're already acceptable because
they've kind of made that you know they
they assume and i think know that their
their peers who are on campus have you
know exceptional educational academic
backgrounds super bright um you know
really talented in a lot of different
ways and that's sort of taken as a given
when you're on these elite campuses and
i you know i think that question might
be that the answer to that might be
different in different kinds of places
um where affirmative action you know
it plays a different role but i think on
these campuses i didn't i didn't hear
that tension i think because of because
of that selection that selection that
already happens before they even get
there
so in in the interviews with the
students of color this notion of perform
you said commander commodifying of
diversity where students of color
in order to better survive would perform
their diversity perform their difference
yeah in kind of a white dominated space
knowing that if they're too much just
like everyone else then they lose their
dive or were they even aware of this
kind of this perception yeah i think
they're probably aware of it i don't
think that they're
feel like they need to kind of play into
that there is definitely a kind of
performance as well i mean students of
color talked and this is not just in my
research other research that shows this
where they feel like they can kind of
let their guard down
in kind of minority-only spaces right so
that there is a real
kind of positive value of like you know
the black students association or you
know um the center for students of color
or these kinds of spaces where they feel
like they're
kind of experience gets foregrounded um
which is not the kind of the dominant
experience in the university right so
that so
the so there is a contrast between you
know in these integrated spaces being
having to have a particular kind of game
face and then feeling like they can sort
of relax
in these minority spaces but again
there's a lot of variation in that um
there are also students of color who
talked about
being in those minority spaces and
feeling like they don't quite fit in for
whatever reason maybe because they came
from a different you know an unusual
kind of class background or they were
adopted or whatever it is um so you know
i think it's complex you know there's so
much diversity among students of color
as well um that shape their experiences
as well so
yeah
hi uh two quick questions for you um the
first one was you said it's echoes um
you mentioned that the gran you had
graduate students do the interviews so
i'm wondering about the inter the
interviewers and how how you think
uh the perceptions of the people who are
doing the interviewing yeah by the
participants may have at all affected
some of the findings you know just in
terms of like who did the interviews if
you could talk about that yeah and if it
was the same people in the different
countries yeah uh and then secondly
so we we have
with this idea that there's these ideas
in these students minds i'm wondering in
terms of the different universities and
the structuring of the extracurricular
experience right you sort of reflected
upon the american college experience and
there's a bit definitely a bigger focus
in the us
on the things that happen outside of
class right and i assume a bigger focus
in britain on the classes uh and so i'm
just curious if there's any kind of
difference in terms of how
i guess how these universities structure
the experience of diversity and how that
may have also affected what people are
talking about when they're answering
questions yeah yeah
so i'll say a little bit about the
methods um
i
so i'd like to do my interviews myself
for my first book i did all my
interviews i'm starting a new project
i'm kind of determined to do all the
interviews myself but for this project i
really felt like if i were going to talk
to white students about race and their
experiences on campus that i couldn't as
a person of color
get
open and honest responses i couldn't
make those students feel comfortable
with me completely comfortable
so i decided that i was going to hire
a white
doctoral student to do these interviews
in the united states i'll talk about
britain in a second
and because of that again i didn't then
i felt like okay if i interviewed the
students of color then that would bias
my own lens having done these interviews
and you know developed a rapport with
the students of color and not even met
have meeting these white students then i
thought that i should interview um hire
and i hired a student of color to
interview the students of color um so
there was one student of color on the
brown campus and one on the harvard a
different student of color on the brown
campus and one white student who did all
the interviews in the united states
in britain it was a little more tricky
because
of class right so the way you speak in
the uk identifies your class identity
right pretty clearly and even i as an
american when i lived there i lived
there for six years after a few years i
could tell i could kind of tell like you
know someone's accent like where they
came from
um
and not always you know to some extent
um
i happen to get around that and i can't
claim that this was
i was i was lucky um so i had i talked
to a colleague at oxford and she
recommended um a doctoral student who
happened to be from western europe um
and uh she was a doctoral student at
oxford and i did i was a little nervous
about that i think in the end it worked
out well because i think she signaled
kind of eliteness through her oxford
through being an oxford student through
being from western europe um but she
also obviously didn't have a class she
had no class markers in her voice um
because she had a foreign accent um and
i think this i think in the end after
the research i felt like in the uk it
would have mattered less because
students said and she did all the
interviews in britain um that students
said things that um i wouldn't have
expected that they would say um in in
polite company um in in the uk to her
so i felt like it didn't it didn't
affect those interviews in the end but i
was a little more nervous about that
um
and so
in terms of extracurriculars and
diversity yeah there's a whole i talk a
lot about this in the book there's a
real kind of institutionalization of
diversity on these campuses britain very
little of that i mean they do have like
minority students groups but that's
really the extent of it
in terms of area studies they'll have
like south asian studies like about
south asia or african cities about
africa but not like asian american
studies or british black studies or
anything like that um on most campuses
um and in the us they're the in in the
harvard and brown differences they they
institutionalize diversity in very
different ways and this is historical as
well as ongoing so for example
um brown so when i did this research
brown's center for students of color was
called the the third world center
they just
a few years ago changed the name to the
brown center for students of color so
you can hear in that name a real
signaling of this is a space for
students of color right and it's a
political you know that third world
identity comes out of the 70s it's very
kind of political
whereas harvard's center for diversity
is called the harvard foundation for
intercultural affairs really focused on
inter you know integration right and
historically as well it was very
deliberately named that when it was
constituted
at the university um there are other
ways in which you know again brown has a
third world transition program um very
different a very particular orientation
harvard's um
uh
orientation program on diversity is like
a 90 minute it's called a community
conversation with their kind of freshman
halls um that don't have the same impact
on students um and so there are all
these um you know i think what that does
is for the students who are
participating at brown they develop a
much more robust understanding of racial
inequality that they didn't learn you
know and i would argue should have
learned in school
um in a language to make meaning of you
know real experiences that they've had
but the white students are very
alienated from that on the brown campus
because they're not part most of them
are not participating and they don't
quite get well why are they all you know
why are they all hanging out a third
world center i don't understand that um
and so they felt very kind of alienated
at harvard
um students students of color and um
white students were much more kind of
positive about the diversity work but it
was you know their big event was the
harvard foundation's big event is the um
um
blinking on the name it's this
multicultural um performance um event um
you probably remember what i'm talking
about i can't think it'll come to me um
when students talked about that as like
a big experience like i had this great
experience with diversity you know the
irish step dancers danced and then the
bhangra like dancers dance and then at
the end they all got together and like
we're on the stage together and you know
we're dancing to this like pop tongue
and so that was their version of
diversity so it was positive and they
appreciated it but again it lacked that
kind of
vision for you know how do we address
racial inequality and so i think you
know i think there are positives and
negatives to both of these models and i
would argue we need to find a way to
institutionalize a model that really
brings all students um
into kind of this understanding
and the complexity of race in the united
states
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here's a look at some of the most in